It's that old boy right behind you. Yeah. Oh my God, dude.
I got a horror movie for people at home.
He told me about this movie like 10 years ago and I that one and then the
audition. Yeah.
Oh, well, I, I, you invited me to your birthday party one time. Yes. And, uh,
I brought you the DVD of old boy as a gift. Yes you did. Yeah.
And I told her to watch it and.
Freaked me out. And I actually, one of the most amazing scenes I've ever seen,
the way that they shot the, uh, the,
the main character is got a whole hallway of people that he has to fight.
So they built this hallway amazing. And they,
they cut out the wall and just had this guy and they just all a one shot
of them going to everybody talks about like the Scorsese, you know,
Goodfellow shot that amazing. When we goes in, this is basically that with like,
he's also fighting 500 people. And then I saw the audition,
um, and I got into like, you know, Asian horror movies and then like,
but they would just, so they was so beyond what we were doing over here,
I was like, this is like bananas. Yeah. I saw a, really a weird one.
Not necessarily scary, but a weird one on the criterion channel.
I saw there's a movie from horror movie from the early seventies called, uh,
let's scare Jessica to death. No, really?
I swear to God let's scare Jessica to death. Yes.
And I'm telling you not necessarily scary as much as it's. It's weird.
I've got the same. Korean is a Korean. No, no, no.
Jessica. Jessica. That's right. Yeah. It wouldn't be Jessica. Yeah. Okay.
Let's scare Jessica to death. It's not scary.
It's weird. It could be because here's the thing. What about horror movies?
Why I don't like him is I buy in. I blew it.
That didn't scare me. That scared the out of me. I know me too. Me too.
All of those movies scared the out of me that, uh, um,
that Baba Duke one stop watch. I shut that off. I was like, I can't handle that,
but then I didn't get to see how the thing gets killed. So for like a month,
every time I turn the lights off, I'm hearing Baba dog. I'm just like, yeah.
I'm kind of a, yeah.
The scariest one I've seen in the week in Indonesia and one. No, no, no.
The one that I want to recommend them is did you see hereditary, hereditary?
Yes.
I won't be because if it freaks you out, but that.
It.
I've seen it three times since we saw it that first time and I
get so scared. You have to watch it, Billy. Please.
Can I ask you a question? Because I don't understand. What is it,
why would you want to feel like,
I hate that feeling like I can watch like a gangster movie, whatever,
but I even watched like casino got to like, yeah, I got a little,
like when he's watching his brother getting, you know, killed, I was just like,
I'm actually, uh, Chris rock is in the, uh,
Fargo and there's a storyline in it.
That's making it on watch as a parent. Yeah. Yeah. Sort of,
uh, I'll trust you with my kid. If you trust me with your kid.
Just trying to get through that. Yeah. It's just like, like, I don't know.
I get like, why I love movies is cause I, I, if I'm into it,
I am I'm in it.
I mean, I can't do rape scenes.
There's this movie called irreversible and there's a 10 minute rape scene in a
tunnel and it's so realistic and literally like
10 seconds in. You're like, all right, I'm out. I'm out. I can't do it. Yeah.
It's so cool. I remember when that movie came up. Yeah.
I remember when that came out. Cause that was a, that was a big a.
Deal. It was a big, it was a controversial.
Does it go backwards? It goes backwards.
Well movie. Yeah. Right. And there's this like, it's like, um.
We'll have editors cut it down. Can I, can I tell you it was,
I've never understood.
I don't understand sex scenes in mainstream Hollywood movies.
I don't understand. Am I now watching a porno
because I watched an old movie one time and these, uh,